- [Mark] Welcome back, Momo.
- Thank you, hi, your welcome.
- [Mark] Nice to see you again.
- Good.
- [Mark] So what's going on
since last time you shot a video
with me, when you were working
the street on Figueroa?
- [Momo] I haven't been
working the street anymore.
- [Mark] Why is that?
- Because my family has been telling me,
like, to let go of it.
And I've been struggling
from working on the street
because I've been needing to
get money to help my family out
with the bills and stuff.
- [Mark] Yeah, your mom was telling me,
you were trying to support the family.
So you keep offering to go out there,
but what have you been doing?
- I've been doing hair.
I've been going outside,
like, walking my dog
each and every day and just doing hair.
Mom have been giving me
clients and stuff to get hair,
and I'm working on making
my website where my hair,
so I could post hair and everything.
And, yeah.
- [Mark] And how does this feel for you?
- Good. I feel happier because it's like,
I don't got to go out to
go make any more money
and I'm not worried about nobody
trying to come get at me
or anything, you know.
- [Mark] It's a safer life doing hair
than working the street
as a prostitute, right?
How does it make you feel about yourself?
- Good, because I feel satisfying
because I don't have to
deal with nobody having
to want money from me
and I can just keep my
money to myself, you know?
And yeah, like I could
spend my money on myself.
Don't gotta worry about nobody.
- [Mark] No, but it's
not just about money,
It's also about how you
feel about yourself.
If you meet a nice boy that you like,
you're gonna feel much better about
how you interact in that relationship
when you're doing hair than when you're
having sex with strangers.
- Right. And I'm trying
to build up my hair point
so I could be able to tell my mother
all the stuff she needs, you know.
- [Mark] So who steered you
clear of what you're doing?
- Huh?
- [Mark] Who helped you get
out of what you were doing?
- My mom mainly, but my
uncle mainly 'cause he,
my mom too, but my uncle,
he was the main one
who was like, telling me,
that I need to work on it
and I need to work on myself
and stop trying to go out
on the streets and stuff.
And stop trying to do
everything everybody else doing
and worry about yourself and stuff.
And just, don't go out on the
streets and stay in the house
to try and find a better
way to work on myself.
- [Mark] And how old are you now?
- I'm 15. I just turned 15,
August 31st I turned 15.
- So when you shared that
video with me last time
you were how old?
- 14.
- [Mark] And you're still in high school.
Or you're gonna be.
- I'm still in high school, yes,
I go to school, today I
just got out of school.
But yeah, I go to school
on my phone, Zoom.
And that's what you do.
And I got back in school,
so I'm working on getting me my laptop
from school and stuff, yeah
- [Mark] That's great.
So how has this affected
your life in other ways?
I mean, other than how
you feel about yourself?
What have your friends...?
- My friends happy, my friends, like, wow
you accomplished something
that we didn't think
you was gonna accomplish and stuff.
And I was like, yeah.
- [Mark] Not many people get out.
- Huh?
- Yeah, you're right, that's
what I was telling you.
I seen people out, I seen you younger,
yeah, I already know.
It's worse out there, but--
- [Mark] It's like people
get addicted to that life,
even if they're not making money.
- Yeah. And then you get
addicted to the streets
and to people's attention
and all that other stuff.
So I feel better.
- [Mark] And then drugs
come into the picture--
- Yeah, drugs, beat, yep--
- [Mark] It's a trap.
- Fights.
Yeah, it ain't no joke.
- [Mark] It's like a trap.
- It's a real trap. So yeah.
I just been working on myself
and yeah, I'm proud of myself
but I'm working on my hair page
but I wanted to try myself out to it
because me before, I
was already doing hair
but now to see me doing more hair,
I'm doing a lot of people
hair and they come over
and like they hair, I
feel better to myself.
Like I don't gotta go out
to show nobody my body
just to get some money or whatever.
- [Mark] Make sure you got
some kind of, like, website
or something that you can throw up
when this video is shot,
appears in a week or so.
- Right.
- [Mark] Well, I'm proud of you, darling.
- [Momo] Thank you.
- [Mark] It's nice to
hear a positive story.
That's great.
All right, thanks for coming back.
- [Momo] You're welcome.
- [Mark] Okay.
You're so cute.
- [Momo] Thank you.